gratulation Mathias du hast die
definitiv ein gutes schweres wichtiges
tiefschürfen des Thema für eine
Feuertaufe ausgesucht es würde mich
Unternehmen was das Erkennen deiner
eigenen kognitiven Dissonanz bezüglich
deine Tierliebe vs des Tier Leids durch
deinen Konsum in den Tagen nach den
Dreharbeiten mit dir gemacht hat
am meisten formuliert Frage an Reporter
was machst du jetzt mit denen der
kognitive die Sonne
zwischen uns und deswegen
Reflexion oder Verhaltensänderung statt
sehr gute Frage
geworden aber es hat mir tatsächlich
Prozess ausgelöst gehabt
und
günstig
essen und ich würde sagen
und ich glaube das wird
Festessen
komplett verändert
aber momentan
ist am meisten Kommentare zum Thema
Fleisch essen
50 41 geschickt persönlich kaufe ich
direkt beim Bauern wenig Fleisch aus
guter Herkunft bei den umliegenden bauen
wenn der Bau dir auf die Frage von
welchem Tier die Wurst ist die den Namen
nennen kann bist du beim richtigen
finden
Biohof hat das Problem hier aus meiner
Kollegin auf dem Biohof die haben wir
auch irgendwie im Schlachthof
und darum
ja ist eigentlich und ich kann auch
beruhigen Spoiler die Katze ist gar kein
Recht
Michelle sv6y ich finde Mathe es geht zu
wenig weiter wenn er am Ende Insekten an
preisst warum nicht Soja und
Hülsenfrüchte für den direkten
menschlichen Verzehr produzieren anstatt
den Umweg über das Insekt frage sie es
geht um dir rum Essen und warum essen
immer andere nicht der
Fokusse pflanzliche Lebensmittel sagen
nachher Grinch 11-20 geschiebt ich habe
es nie verstanden warum die Leute so
abgeneigt sind Katzen oder Hunde zu
essen wer aus ethischen Gründen keine
Hunde oder Katzen essen will soll
aufhören Fleisch zu essen es ist einfach
scheinheilig zu sagen Katzen dürfte man
nicht essen während man jeden Tag ein
Stück Schwein auf dem Teller hat in eine
andere Richtung geht der Kommentar vor
Hafermilch lässt Bauern Blut was du
nicht willst was man die tut das füge
auch keinem anderen zu ich möchte nicht
dass mir eine andere Spezies mit einem
Bolzenschussgerät in den Kopf schießt
darum mache ich es auch nicht und lebe
ein zufriedenes veganes Leben und es
gibt keinen Unterschied zwischen Hund
Katze Pferd Schwein oder Mensch alles
sind fühlende Lebewesen die leben wollen
haben
Markus wild sehen
die Unterschiede machen das ist
kulturell bedingt das ist so wichtig
geworden ist sehr lang schon so die
Ideen damit das Ganze da drin lässt
schon Kommentare kann ein dunkler
Gedanke essen wie nicht einfach die
friedlichsten Tiere die sich kaum gegen
Gefangenschaft und Ausbeutung und die
Tötung gegen ihren Willen während
die Frage
mir ist die dir ausgesucht hey wo wir
perfekt züchtet und perfekt geformt
hätte dass sie ist eine Bedürfnis vom
Fleischkonsum gerecht werden die Antwort
hat nie die Treppe geschafft aber ich
möchte jetzt hier zeigen also zum
Beispiel es machst tun dass wir Züchter
zu möglichst viel Fleisch ersetzen oder
bestimmt die versuchsmoos die wird
genetisch auf die Linie züchtet das
heißt mehr manipuliere dir ja die
Kategorien und viel vor deiner dir wo
mir züchtet die könnte dir wilde
Bedingungen gegangen überleben also es
macht tun in der Wildnisse Chance
nachher fresh pink eine Nacht ist es
nicht so dass sie grundsätzlich
Pflanzenfresser Essen Rindt Pferd scharf
hätte etc Winter Natur die Raubtiere
Fleischfresser auch Pflanzenfresser als
heute haben und wir auch deshalb Katze
und Hund nicht auf unserem Speiseplan
haben ja genau
grundsätzlich kein Raubtier Essen
Fischer
es hat auch einige Kommentare zu der
Tabea sie wo ihr die Hühner so pflegt
wie Haustier da zum Beispiel torrex 7400
übertreibt extrem ihre Liebe und
Fürsorge für die Viecher sind zum kotzen
das hat die Zukunft
[Musik]
hier kassiert so herzlich umgehen die
Ordnung
ich frage stellen
okay ich will jetzt essen ich Frage
stellen
zum Beispiel vom alayaks 92 ich bin seit
30 Jahren Vegetarier super endlich mal
eine Sendung zu diesem Thema die nicht
belehrend oder moralisch daherkommt sehr
gut gemacht einfach transparent und
tragend ohne vorgefertigte Antwort zu
Präsentieren
von heute vor der Monika Polanco
6286 ich kenne diese dissonante sehr gut
mir ist es wichtig dass das Tier dass
ich esse ein schönes Leben hatte und
einen schnellen Tod meine eigenen Tiere
kann ich auch nicht essen mein Sohn
schon er hat sein Huhn mit Liebe
großgezogen und war beim Metzger dabei
und hat dann sein Huhn mit Genuss
gegessen das ist auch eine Art der
Wertschätzung unserer Tiere gegenüber
ja so alles machen
wie konsequenter als minihhaltig wo aber
vielleicht lieber gar nicht so genau
wissen das ist tierisch gesehen das ist
sie
Person von der Monika
ist immerhin konsequent wenn der Moment
Kollegen von SRF impact die hey Film
gemacht vom Lebewesen zur Wurst ist
Fleischkonsum mit Tierwohl zu
vereinbaren einfach hier klicken